- So I couldn't help but notice,
that in your new lovely book,
it started here, like after you were here.
- It did, we were right
over there cooking.
- I know.
Making a crab and cheesy dip.
- Which I don't cook well,
but I love the discernment.
- You made that great dip.
(giggles)
- Because of you.
(giggling simultaneously)
- And then, oh yes, there we are.
And then I took the
leftovers 'cause I always,
you know have stuff at home too,
because I'm always
practicing before I do it.
And I took it over to Wolfe's house
and that's when Ed came by,
and it all starts the whole story of
this reconnection that Ed and I had
in the last few years of his life.
- Oh, wow.
- Yeah.
- That must have been hard.
I know because I've
gone through a divorce,
still going through divorce,
and it's like, it feels,
it's a weird thing, but
it feels like a death.
- Yeah.
- Like it feels like such a loss,
like divorce in general,
and then to lose him again,
that must have been really hard.
- Yeah, it sucks.
- 'Cause it's your kid's
father too, you know?
Yeah.
- Yeah, but there was something,
and I know so many people get mad at me
when I say that there was a love that Ed
and I had that no one really can.
And it's, but it's true.
I mean, I don't know why was it.
- Why do they get mad,
but that's a beautiful thing?
- Because we were both
married to other people.
But it wasn't,
it was nothing sexual.
It was nothing.
It was just, I've known the
guy since I was 20 years old.
I was a baby,
and he was just my life
for a very long time.
So I'm a little uncomfortable
talking about it,
but I'm not because there's
nothing to be ashamed of
when you love somebody.
- Yeah.
- Love is love.
- I think there's room
to love a lot of people
and there are different types of love.
- Yes, yes.
- Yeah. Oh.
- And it turned into like brother, sister
and I care about him so much.
Still do.
- Yeah.
- Still do.
Why did you call the
book "Enough Already"?
And it's,
I love that "Learning to
love the way I am today".
- Because, I'm done.
I'm just done judging myself.
I'm done with all the
negative talk that I give
to myself because there's
enough negative talk out there.
It's just enough already, enough.
Enough getting on the scale,
enough saying horrible
things about myself.
- Yeah.
- And just changing the perspective,
and changing,
- The narrative.
- The view and the narrative, thank you.
And also, I am enough.
I'm enough.
- Yeah.
- It's enough.
- It's so interesting,
'cause from an outsider's
perspective and just even
having the one lunch we got
to share, like it was like
I literally remember
leaving and telling Ashley,
I was like, man, she is such a light.
She's so kind.
She's so normal.
You were so cool.
Like rarely
- I thought the same thing about you.
- Well what's funny is, rarely
do you meet people like,
- In this business.
- You know, we're always working
and busy, busy and rarely
do I really find that.
And so I had advice actually
given to me for 2022.
And it was like treat
yourself how you treat other.
Oh no, yes treat yourself
how you treat others.
And it's like, 'cause
I feel like we are kind
to people a lot often
more than to ourselves.
- Yes, unfortunately
- Which so crappy.
- Right.
And it's not okay.
- Why do we do that?
- I don't know
I mean, it's just, I
learned from a very, very
very young age by, you
know, just the way you watch
and the way you see the way
people treat each other.
That it's just the certain
things that you're allowed to say
and not allowed to say
and not allowed to feel.
And I learned at a young age that,
gaining weight was
unlovable, made me unlovable.
- Wow.
- So I'm still trying to purge
that out of my system because
it's not, that's not true.
It's just a lie.
- No, yeah, that's,
oh my gosh that's so sad.
I think that's a thing in the
South that said a lot too.
- Everywhere.
- I don't know if its everywhere.
- All over the world.
- Yeah.
That's definitely in the South.
But I, also I think what
I am glad about is,
I think so many things
happened to me when I was young
about my weight that I think
like even at a young age,
like so many things get said,
that I think that's whenever
I was just like, whatever
I'm not gonna please anyone.
- God bless you.
- I think I was lucky
it happened because it
before I got in the
industry, because it was like
'cause it literal in the industry.
You're talking about your
son being in the industry.
It's very hard.
Even for men.
- Yes.
- Even for men.
- To look a certain way
and do with certain things
and it's, and it's just
such a silly thing.
And I love the title.
- Thank you.
- "Enough Already".
'Cause it's very, welcoming
to so many people that have the same fight
within themselves.
- That they're trying to overcome.
- It's hard when you learn
as a little girl and then
trying to get that out.
So for you to break that as a little girl.
- Yeah.
- Is something to be really proud of.
It took me a long time.
I mean I watched my mom not get loved
by my dad when she would gain weight.
- Oh God!
- I had an elementary school teacher point
at my belly and say,
"you better watch that".
And I didn't even realize
I had a body before that.
Like I had no awareness
of what I looked like.
It was just like, let's have fun.
And then all of a sudden I was like,
oh I'm supposed to look a certain way?
- Oh!
- Yeah, that's damaging.
- That's not okay.
- Yeah.
No you gotta be so careful with what you
say in front of the little
ones, they're sponges